so this is a balloon helium and helium
is very small gas we use in this case to
find leaks in high pressure and high-end
vacuum apparatus because it's very very
small finds the smallest smallest holes
but just like hydrogen it's also very
very light and you know in the past we
use hydrogen to fill balloons for
transport and now you see the Goodyear
blimp sporting occasions it's filled
with helium so helium is probably the
most unreactive of the elements it has a
mass of four so it weighs four times as
much as a hydrogen atom but hydrogen
exists as an h2 molecule where's helium
exists as isolated atoms so that helium
molecule weighs twice as much as
hydrogen so here we have a hydrogen well
we have a helium filled balloon and it's
extremely light so I'm not going to let
it go right now so I will lose it to the
ceiling so we're just going to put on a
piece of string tie lead around it again
helium cannot be synthesized in nature
because because it is just an element it
is found as a component of natural gas
in some places particularly in the
United States because it is formed by
the radioactive decay of minerals in
underground and these form helium which
is trapped with the natural gas so here
we have our helium balloon floating
because it's displacing it's volume of
air and it'll float quite nicely it's
actually quite hard to contain so the
piece of string and heavy stand as
they're holding it down because we don't
really want to lose it if we take a
balloon of another light gas and that's
hydrogen and we add a match to it or we
set it on fire it'll burn really really
quickly and really energetically because
it makes from lots and lots of water
hydrogen plus oxygen then we're going to
do the same experiment now but we're
going to do it with a helium filled
balloon and see if that will burn so
here we have a technical match on a
stick and we're going to offer it up to
our floating balloon of helium let's see
what happens this time a little bit of a
bang but that's just a bang of the gas
escaping it didn't burn yeah it's
unreactive it's an inert gas the
molecule is very light so once it is in
the atmosphere it will eventually get
and go
out into outer space so that we are in
theory at least likely to run out of
helium in the eventual future if it is
just released to the atmosphere so what
I got here is a balloon of helium yeah
and it's really really light and it's
displacing a lot of volume so if I let
go that it's good it's going to fly like
a hot like a balloon so what we're going
to do is I'm going to hold it down here
and Neil is going to cool it for me
using some liquid nitrogen now you can
see Neil is using the gloves because
it's very very cold okay so as he cools
the balloon the gas is inside are
slowing down and they take up much much
less volume as we slow them down and now
you can see it's displacing less volume
so the balloon is quite happy to sit on
the table if we if we stop pouring the
liquid nitrogen onto it now and watch
what happens as the balloon starts to
warm up again because the gases are
gaining more energy and they were
occupying more space and becoming more
buoyant so the helium is gone back to
the ceiling where it really wants to be
the helium has a whole series of useful
properties because it's a very light gas
if you breathe in helium you then start
speaking like Donald Duck in the very
squeaky voice he and fantastic element
very light very fun because the speed of
sound is much greater in helium than it
is in ordinary gases it is also very
useful as a liquid it only liquefies at
very low temperature its boiling point
is minus 269 degrees centigrade but if
you pull things with liquid helium you
get very strange properties for example
some materials lose their electrical
resistance so liquid helium is used for
magnets when you need very powerful
magnets and for example they're used in
hospital magnets for magnetic resonance
imaging in hospitals if you use a vacuum
pump to pump
hard on the helium the boiling point
will go even lower and you can go to
nearly 2 degrees absolute and so helium
is very important for all sorts of
refrigeration